john smoltz was on the call and he makes
it look easy folks it's not that easy
but that's why john's one of the best in
the business the fox analyst
and uh hall of famer you can watch john
and joe buck they call the world series
on fox that begins tomorrow night
plus mlb is airing live coverage before
and after every game
on mlb tonight john how you feeling
today
well i'm feeling good uh especially you
know i'm not gonna lie
especially that uh there's not the uh
west coast to east coast travel that
would be pretty interesting when you
think about the dodgers
and tampa bay so both clubs
get to stay here and both clubs get to
probably play their best baseball
considering there's not a lot of travel
to go on but also how you set up your
rotation
and your pitching staff that you're
playing just about every day i think
there's a break after game two and game
five
but we've seen the depth take over that
you need to have those
arms because you were playing every day
how does that affect the world series in
your opinion
yeah so you know what the dodgers did um
or what they were capable of doing
they might have done some things a lot
of people thought were a little bit
outside the box and didn't have to do
but they had so much
depth that it actually won over in a
seven game series where there were no
day offs this time i think you'll have
the flexibility
to play it closer to the way that you
you would typically play a world series
you won't need five starters
you may not need four but what i was
interested to see and
played out the way i thought it would
when starting pitching which in
this playoffs was not a strength for a
lot of clubs the two better
teams of starting pitchering ended up
being where they needed to be and i
thought that the raise with their great
bullpen but their great starting
pitching
is the reason they're there and
certainly they went they went full
board they went five games and seven
games to get here
the dodgers had a relatively easy route
until this seven game series and they
were pushed to the limit
by the braves in a way i don't think
anyone could have anticipated the series
to go the way it did there's pressure on
the dodgers but what is that like when
you're expected to win
it yeah it's real difficult because you
know there's so much talk about history
and what you haven't done
and you forget that the year you had was
pretty good
and i think that you know having lived
it through 95 getting into the 95 world
series we had lost two previously
and you know people were starting to
compare us to teams that
you know whether it was the bills which
i never understood but that that
pressure on you
causes you um to have to think about
things you never would think about you
really won't want to think about
competing and executing and i think the
dodgers have handled it pretty well
knowing that they had the best team but
knowing also that all eyes were on them
waiting for stories to be written about
what they haven't done since 1988
and those stories are still there but
their relief is
is obviously greater today than it was
uh 24 hours ago
and it always goes back to clayton
kershaw he has a chance
to kind of rewrite his playoff resume or
the history of that
he pitched well earlier in the playoffs
like what what is it about clayton when
he gets in these moments here because it
this is habit it's not a coincidence
anymore what is it about these moments
for him
well individually everything seems to go
um
with that heavy weight of what the
collective
up uh performances have been for him in
the postseason and what i mean by that
is
they're individually different and they
collectively add a narrative that
you know isn't totally fair but you can
understand and if you're clayton kershaw
you want to shed some of that pounds
that he's been carrying
he doesn't have to do it anymore he
doesn't have to carry the franchise he
doesn't have to pitch on three days rest
doesn't have to log 240 innings
and i think everybody rises the occasion
when they face clayton kershaw and the
pitching performance you could not have
expected from bryce wilson but he did it
he actually outpitched
clayton kershaw and the pressure builds
the closer the game is
because i think clayton depends on
his intensity and his want to is so
great that sometimes i think
the want to and the desire can out can
outperform
can outrun your performance and and that
is just something no one could
understand
because not a lot of people are in his
shoes where uh the world's greatest
pitcher in the regular season
has impossible standards to live up when
it comes to the postseason but you're
right
that it does fall into the execution
level and it hasn't been
like it has been for the regular season
but you find that there are certain
teams like the houston rockets to me are
built for the regular season they're
they're teams that are built
milwaukee bucks were built for the
regular season when you get into that
you know five game seven game series
where teams really do their research on
you their homework on you
you pitched with glavine and maddox they
were
average in the postseason their hall of
famers 300 wins in the regular season
you may be not as dominating in the
regular season but were dominating in
the postseason
like curt schilling like they're just
there's certain pictures where you go
you know why and why not i think the
biggest
or the easiest answer would be as per as
perfect as those guys were in the
regular season there's a tendency that
you think you think you have to be
even more perfect and there's no way you
can and to be
that finite you can put so much
attention on the detail and forget
that you are the pitcher you are and and
i used to think you know when you get to
the postseason
the strike zone changes a little bit the
attention to detail nobody
uh approaches the at-bats like they
would in the regular season look i
watched
maddox and glab and carve people up and
rightfully so because their ego
when they got to the box was i'm gonna
i'm gonna take this guy deep and they'd
ground out
well in the post season you change and
if you don't kind of have the stuff in
the zone
it definitely makes it tougher and i
think there's a combination of a lot of
those things but let's
the other thing is there's a lot of
close games that don't go your way and
they just add to the narrative there's
been three significantly
weird games that clayton pitched and
would never pitch again two of them
against the cardinals
i think seven innings in it seven runs
in an inning where he had the game
totally won and those things are the
things that you remember and those are
probably the hardest things for clayton
to go oh no here we go
but i can promise you you know leading
into the the braves game he dominated
and no one you know you just think about
the braves game but he dominated in the
postseason
and he really pitched a much better than
the results against the
the braves your thoughts on mookie betts
as an all-around talent yeah he's always
been that guy for me that if you had to
pay a ticket to watch him play the game
i'm you know what i'm glad i'm glad he's
an outfielder because if
he's an infielder he'd just be another
average guy in the shift
but as an outfielder he gets to showcase
his talent his speed his arm
you know rob home runs use the speed on
the bases but if he was an infielder he
would just be
another guy in the shift that we would
talk about the shift and not the
athletic talent of the player and i i'm
telling you
he's he'd be a center fielder on most
teams he happens to play on a team where
you know bellinger is just as good of an
outfielder and i think the catches he
made
the hardest catch was the one against
against ozuna that was
an impossible catch that he made look
easy
the game changers are the one you talk
about you know he made that catch it was
difficult for ozuna to see if he had
caught it or not and got caught in
between
but the game saving cats in the game
seven you dream of those you dream of a
home run robbing catch
that turns around the series and the
dodgers did just enough
to make the momentum switch their favor
i had not heard that before that
infielders don't get the chance to
really showcase their talent because we
have shifts on just about
every other batter there whereas the
athleticism
can be on display in the outfield
because that's where most of the balls
are ending up you know they're fly balls
home runs those kind of things is that
what you're saying about
yeah absolutely i mean you used to have
a decided advantage when you think about
traditional uh positioning when
ozzie smith was a shortstop for the
cardinals they had an advantage over the
rest of the shortstops
but now if ozzie smith was playing today
he'd be playing more second base
than he would shortstop or in the hole
so it definitely takes away some of the
athleticism of the
of the showcasing of the individuals so
no doubt an outfielder can
can shine are you going to play golf
today i'm not
i'm taking i'm taking today off wow
john smoltz not playing golf today big
story here
i'm a little gassed and we got one day
off to get ready for the raise
uh it'll be a heavy uh heavy work day
today and tomorrow and then
then you'll see some uh relaxation you
got a golf course there
in texas you're gonna go to there's a
ton there's so many good golf courses
here and you know the beauty of being
here 27 straight days
is that uh you get a chance to to visit
some of those golf courses that are
close dallas national trinity forest
yeah there's some
some beautiful golf courses here who do
you uh who do you have in the world
series
well as broadcaster i have the dodgers
and the race
who do you think is going to win between
the dozens
of predictions but i will tell you this
i will tell you between the two teams
uh i still maintain i know it's it's
it's well documented that the rays hit
homers and strike out a lot maybe don't
have the highest batting average
and the dodgers are the opposite offense
i still think
uh that when it comes down to two great
teams two best records in baseball
i think the team that puts the ball and
play the most is going to win
i really do i it has been that case for
the last 15 to 19 years
the rays have a chance to buck the trend
i think they're the top third i think
their third most strikeouts in all the
baseball they have a chance to to win a
world series
in that category that we haven't seen in
20 years now when the shift
happens and the third base line is open
and all you have to do is lay down a
bunch on
yeah but why don't guys do that
uh it's not it's not there's no reward
for them there's not it the clubs don't
want them to do it it's it's not because
they can't do it it's just that
there is no emphasis on that being a
priority
when the game has the ball in the air
for homers and and strikeouts and walks
that's what you're promoting that's what
the guys are perfecting
look velocity is that way the way it is
people will say well it's just not that
hard i mean it's just not that easy you
anything that you practice is easier
than if you try to do it
when you've never done it before and i
think that's the difference in
when you have situations i get nervous
in the booth
i'm not pitching anymore i get nervous
in the booth in the eighth or ninth
inning and see that and go
i could potentially lose a game on that
a swing
by accident but but
when you have the numbers that show and
the and and the players just unwillingly
do it then there's no real risk in the
club
defending the way they're defending man
it's just such a
it's just a different game it's crazy it
just it is there were some situations in
this series where you saw the bunt come
into play
more than ever uh the braves tried it a
couple times the
the play that that the first and third
with one out or less is you can't defend
it you're just
impossible to defend the safety bunt you
just can't defend it and and nobody
really has that up their sleeve yet um
hasn't practiced that for
you know it's like it's like the nba
team that doesn't play defense in the
regular season you go okay play defense
in the postseason well that ain't going
to happen
it's you are what you are and and you
have to be able to
maximize the guys in their position i
the the most i've ever been shocked is
that runners on first and second and
most clubs are teaching the guy get the
ball off the ground they do not whatever
do not hit the ball on the ground
because they'd rather you strike out
then hit into a double play have two
outs versus one out so that's just the
way it is and
players have learned to uh adjust
accordingly does it
matter when you're throwing 96 97
90 like these guys they've seen these
pitches so it's not like
you know when we're growing up and
somebody threw gas we're like whoa
yeah like 95 is nothing that's like
off-speed pitches to these guys but
when does speed get somebody's attention
in the batter's box
i think when you have two or three
pitches you can throw for strikes if
you've got a 98 99 mile or fastball
um you could throw it 20 times in a row
it could be the fastest pitch in the
world they're going to hit it
if you don't locate it they're going to
hit it if you don't do something else
to show that you can throw another pitch
you're in trouble it doesn't matter how
hard you throw yeah
the thing that's amazing to me is that
when you have all this velocity and all
this effort
you know you're just asking guys for
short sprints which i get
you know at this point i still think the
dodgers do the best job of making you
really earn everything that you can they
have not
it's been amazing what they do
collectively it's not like just one or
two guys
so you're gonna see that same discipline
on display this week and
the br i've never seen a collective arms
uh the rays have i've never seen
this many filthy arms in my life 100
miles an hour 99 98 and they coming out
left and right
matter of fact last series they brought
in two guys hadn't even heard of
that's how many guys they've had and so
that's why the homework i have will be
but they they have the ability to mix
and match with velocity but you have to
have
a secondary pitch i think you're tipping
your pitches right now john
i might be i know i'm tipping i gotta
check the video after we're done here
and see
yeah i get it yeah who would tell you
you're tipping your pitches
well i wish i would have learned someone
would have told me in 2009
when i was with the red sox but
usually you have your club okay you have
a little bit of time tell that story
and i d i stumbled upon it i didn't mean
to bring it up but you're on the mound
pitching for the red sox
and well i'm i'm i'm not very good at
this point trying to come back and then
it's a relief to find out when i got to
st
louis my first bullpen session chris
carpenter said do you mind if i tell you
something i said absolutely he goes
i know every pitch you're throwing i
said oh well if you know every pitch i'm
throwing in a bullpen
then everyone knows every pitch i've
been throwing in the real game and it
was with my glove
and i changed that in the bullpen and
that very first game for the
st louis cardinals i think i still hold
the franchise record i struck seven guys
seven guys are in a row out for the
padres and it was such a relief because
i was grinding
so hard for boston i wanted to do so
well and
it felt like now looking back everybody
knew it was coming they were hitting
balls out of the stadium
so so when you're broke down trying to
perform you're thinking
well certainly somebody could have
picked that up but
it didn't happen then and thankfully uh
chris carpenter saw it
do we look at the astros differently
after this postseason
i think you have to i mean noah you know
i understand
what if i was a player i would encourage
everybody but that just just kind of be
as quiet as you need to let your playing
do your
your talking i think what they were able
to do uh they gained some respect i
don't think they gained
a lot of respect from fans that still
don't want to hear
you know give it a year next year i
think everything will be
uh back to normal they played an
incredible series
and yes they had a lot of people hoping
things didn't work out for the obvious
for what they went through and what they
were part of
but collectively i think they gained a
lot of respect thank you john great job
and uh we'll look forward to talking to
you and listening uh world series starts
tuesday night with uh joe buck on fox
thank you buddy you got it thanks for
having me that's
john smoltz